he wanted
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
one
one
[Music]
two three
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
check check check one two one two one
two well I mean I guess the stream
elements ghost is here
the stream elements ghost is working
but nothing else
welcome to Retro raconteur live ladies
and gentlemen
lots of uh little changes here to talk
about lots of little changes you notice
we don't have our Halloween music
tonight
because we got a copyright hold on not a
strike a strike's the bad one
straight A strike's a really bad one we
got a copyright claim
on our past two live streams despite
there being something
on the the music that we were using
saying copyright free and saying all you
have to do is put our
you know they have a little thing they
want you to put in the description which
I did on both videos I did
and nope we still got we still got a
copyright claim and so
they have a little thing where you can
email
and then if you email the people and
tell them hey you know this video is
monetized here's the link here's where I
gave you guys credit then they're
supposed to go in or at least so they
say they go in and they release the
claim well they never did on mine
so what I basically had to do if you
guys go back and you watch the live
stream from last week the week before is
not too bad because it was mostly in the
beginning like when it's doing the
countdown YouTube's automatic system
detects it
and then it kicks it you know
kicks off my monetization so that one
was fine because I just trimmed it out
well this one it actually happened in
the beginning which is fine because it's
easy for me to trim that out and I'm not
really doing any commentary anyway so I
get you know you wouldn't want that in
there
because that's just me playing their
music so I get that so I trimmed that
out but then it also affected the uh
for those of you who were here last week
we did a little quiz a little Dumbledore
quiz and I guess I would I wasn't
talking enough consistently
so it was like picking up the music
while I was
contemplating
so if you go back and you if anybody has
went back and watched that's why there's
there's some random jumps because I had
to just go in and cut out those sections
on YouTube
um yeah they never got back to me I sent
them the email and they never got back
IRT with 500 SEK
I have no idea how much that is fire tea
but thank you so much hold on I need to
look this up
regardless of how much it is
let's see s-e-k to USD
here we go hold on I think it's five
dollars
no wait wait wait
is that 44 is that like fifty dollars
oh my goodness fire tea
that is insane thank you so much dude
hello and good evening I hope you are
doing well I just wanted to ask if you
will play any horror games this October
and also show my support have an awesome
day
wow that is awesome my friend thank you
so much
getting getting things started with a
bang here
uh I see you rocking the the new Emoji
nice everybody who's a channel member
there
we got the new emoji that was that was
another stream update so we had a bad
stream update with the whole music thing
but
I just have to be more careful about
what we play so what we're playing
tonight is approved these are Spotify
playlists from people like Harris Heller
uh uh
oh gosh Ninja's uh brother bearded
Blevins has his own thing now I've got
him on here I've got a twitch music
library we've got no copyright so
hopefully
we're good with all of these
um
yeah it's just it's unfortunate because
we thought we were doing everything
right but it's not a huge deal it's
really not uh as for any horror games I
am not a big Horror Game Fan
I am not a big fan the about the most
horror I get
I don't know I guess it is horror
Resident Evil like I love the Resident
Evil games I love bloodborne I actually
haven't played the latest Resident Evil
so that one might be a fun one to do I
have Resident Evil 2 the Remake on PC I
played through that loved it
but yeah we haven't really been having a
lot of time for gameplay streams
actually
I'd love to do more gameplay streams but
we just haven't had much time for them
but if you guys have any uh I don't do
the I don't do the games that are purely
existing just to scare me I don't do
those I gotta have some action you know
there's got to be some I've got to be
able to take control
and just like obliterate some zombies or
something I don't want to just be you
know these um
oh man I was watching some the the more
Mortuary assistant
oh my gosh that game looks incredibly
creepy
that was why I was watching a trailer
that no thank you no thank you not
happening whatsoever
elf on a shelf how about Lincoln a
bucket right right yeah that was a 45
okay this is awesome
I made some updates to the stream that I
thought I thought everything was going
to be working nice and uh Wonderful
Tonight
but unfortunately stream elements has
just decided not to show up
but everything else is looking good I
have a a new activity feed which you
guys can't see this but over here on the
right whenever I get behind like right
now
I see we've already got some re uh new
members here that I need to catch up on
all of this stuff will show up over here
on the right side for me which is really
nice
so we also had Ravenclaw Tyrell
remember for two months and then we also
had Jake let's go remember for three
months Jake welcome back I saw some of
your pictures in the Discord dude it
looked like he had an awesome time
let us know all about it how it went
Jake just went to uh The Wizarding World
down in in Orlando so
Dr sherbet sounds like a lot I know
right
there was one time on expecto ghost
stream somebody gave him uh
I think it was 500 something
and we couldn't figure out we finally
figured because I was like I don't think
he realized how much that was
and then he went back and I think we
figured out it was five dollars but
still
five dollars is amazing
and fire tea out here with a 45 Super
Chat to get us started oh there goes the
go see all the other stream element
stuff is working magnificently
Dylan how's it going Dylan welcome back
remember for four months hit that like
button for our favorite dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
I don't know if you guys saw YouTube's
got some new updates I don't think
they're officially live yet but some new
updates in terms of uh
where the like button and where or maybe
it's the Subscribe where the Subscribe
button and then the join button are
gonna be positioned it should be a lot
easier for you guys now I think
to subscribe for mobile once all this
goes live or to uh to become members on
mobile and then there's Elwyn with a
gifted
five memberships gifted from Elwyn elwin
thank you so much for the support let's
see who gets these uh oh wait you know
hold on hold on hold on
there it is how are you I was afraid it
wasn't working
I was afraid it wasn't working for a
second
oh and this is awesome I could even I
could even hit the little drop down and
I can see exactly who gets oh you guys
can't see this but trust me it's
beautiful over here this little activity
feed I have now
so beautiful so I can see Draven ether
Travis Professor Abbott and Michael all
just got a gifted tier one membership
from Elwyn elwin thank you so much for
the gifted memberships
Elvin says woo been here one month now
and has it only been one month oh and
that's crazy
that it's only been one month Ellen
thank you so much for the two months
and then for all those gifted
memberships by the way guys Elwyn new
moderator here on the channel as well so
we got I'm trying to build up our
moderator team here so we have
I know I stream it kind of it's late
hours and some of you have to turn in
early I get it
so I want to make sure we got a nice uh
range here
so we got elwin we got Nico we got Dylan
as a moderator and then Christy as soon
as Christy Pops in Christy is going to
be a new moderator as well YouTube makes
it actually kind of confusing to uh make
people moderators so the easiest way to
do it is for me to see their name in the
chat and then I could just click and
make it happen
but uh yeah I reached out to both
Christy and Owen because they are
frequently here they get what this
community is all about as do Nico and uh
Dylan and Nico and Dylan are also
moderators over on the Discord and I
believe I know Stargazer Tim is a
moderator on the Discord
I can't remember if I've made him a
moderator here or not either I know it's
always kind of late for him so
but yeah
be be kind guys we got we got lots of
moderators which honestly you guys
rarely need any moderation at all
stream continues to grow though I want
to be prepared just in case you know
just in case
I want to be prepared
all right so I'm gonna try something new
for oh wait top chat or live chat we
want live chat I want to see all
messages
I want to see all the messages here oh
wait stream elements ladies and
gentlemen did stream elements hold on
hold on
I think stream elements may have finally
decided to show up for duty tonight
let's see let's see if they decided to
show up
wait wait wait oh
stream elements you have finally arrived
stream elements thank you for deciding
to show up for work tonight where you're
only about uh let's see actually start
the stream about 8 20. so they're what I
don't know 20 minutes late
what's up with that
Jake thank you so much for that Super
Chat as well 1.99 I'm free it's 7 39
where I'm from let me know wait what
are you asking are you trying to find a
date Jake what's going on here
7 39 hit me up who are you talking to
here Jake
oh goodness Jake thanks so much for the
Super Chat yeah it's 8 41 for me and I
saw somebody posted early in the Stream
saying hey it's not um
it's not like 2 A.M or something 8 30 is
usually when we start 8 30 Eastern Time
Jay Rossi in the house as well what's up
Jay Rossi oh yeah I remember what I was
gonna do I said I was going to try
something new okay so I'm just gonna hit
participants
that can't be right there's way more of
you in here than that maybe these are
only the Chatters though
this might be a lot easier you guys know
I always like to start the stream
shouting out everybody and we really
don't have a lot of news to talk about
tonight
so I know usually some a lot of people
only come for the news and some people
start getting a little antsy when we
don't get right into the news when we
don't just go right into it
I'm like look if you want to know just
the news you can you know you can go and
read about it this is a stream we're
here we're hanging out we're chatting
we're interacting we're talking
so I'm gonna shout out everybody who's
here
showing love in the chat and I think
this is going to be a much easier way
instead of me trying to go through all
the comments there's another little uh
drop down here
no not top chat I want to see live chat
I want to see everything all right
participants okay so we got Alan C in
the house we got Arcane Master 39 CT 707
wolf Trooper Channel member is here as
well as Dr sherbet in the house don't
disrespect to go the poppy
welcome thank you so much for being here
Draven is here Dylan is here Elwyn fire
tea Gabe Jake all channel members right
there we got house
in the house once again Jay Rossi
Channel member Jagged wizard James I
think James just got one of the gifted
memberships James welcome uh kinda hi
Jedi welcome Christy there's Christy
all right I see Christy in here let me
see if I can click on her name now
oh I see you Christy I see you all right
Christy
oh why is it not working
why is it not working
come on dude come on
I'm trying to moderate to moderate I'm
trying to mod you Christy right now I
was telling everybody earlier yeah time
for the promo the promotion but it just
stopped work like it's not letting me
just when stream element starts to work
then YouTube's just like nah not
happening
all right we'll try to we'll try to get
that in a second but we got Christy here
in the house lowercase Logan welcome
back dude lowercase Logan is here as
well
uh let's see we got Lucas in the house
we got Mark mutant Pogo that's a pretty
cool name mutant Pogo
Noob back in the house as well Nathan is
here Neko is here Nico is here oh no
this person told me how to pronounce the
name last time
they told me how to pronounce it and I'm
gonna get it way wrong
it's p-a-n-e-d-h-i-e-l
Ana deal
that's wrong I'm so sorry channel number
two but thank you so much for being here
Ravenclaw Tyrell Ryan Kingsbury in the
house Sharon is here stream elements
they finally decided to show up Ultra
Blue Jr VVS Broly Wally Waldo an extra
white Channel member there all in the
house tonight
I see Jason see now this is the bad part
when I when I do it like this
it's in alphabetical order so anybody
like I already see some names that have
that have jumped in since I started
reading them
so then you just like
you just get left out I'm sorry
but now I can jump back to chat
oh there's see there Kitty there we go
so we're gonna talk
we're gonna talk about the game or not
I know Kitty was just joking there Kitty
was just joking uh we got another 4.99
from Jake here forgot to ask how do I
become a mod also showing support
problem in the last one Jake it's all
good my friend you don't have to like
please never feel obligated to donate
never feel obligated to donate
uh how do you become a mod well right
now we're probably in a pretty good
place at this point
but I appreciate the volunteers yeah I I
feel like
four is gonna be a good number for where
we're at currently
um maybe five if I I can't remember if I
if I if Stargazer Tim is a mod or not
yet but if stargies or Tim is mod that
would be five so yeah it's um Nico Dylan
and then Elwyn and Christy as soon as I
can get this to work
what if I refresh this is it gonna kill
the Stream
no it shouldn't this is on my uh
actually you know what let me try to
pull it up here I'm just gonna go up to
my
try to pull up the
just like as if I were a viewer
watching an ad on my own video
okay there we go there we go there we go
okay put user in timeout no
I'm kidding I didn't hit that uh okay
make sure I'm on Christy here
add moderator
Christy Gene Dyer is now a moderator for
your channel congratulations all right I
think it worked there
I think it worked so now all of our
moderators are in place and honestly
guys the moderators are just here to
make sure that
everybody stays respectful we don't have
people spamming links uh if you watch a
lot of
I don't know if this is a YouTube
problem I guess it does happen on Twitch
too but I've seen a lot of streams that
will get just random spam and we kind of
prevent some of that because we have the
you have to subscribe to even be able to
chat in in our chat here subscriptions
are free on YouTube so you have to be
able to subscribe before you can chat at
all
so turning that on helps with a lot
but
it's basically to help with with things
like that you know keep the
family-friendly Vibes a family-friendly
atmosphere going Noob with a super chat
I'll be here to help out any way I can
my friend Noob thank you so much with
the 2.23 Super Chat and Noob you know
what you didn't say it you didn't say it
but I'm gonna go ahead
and I'm gonna take a drink here because
it's always good to stay hydrated my
friends
tonight we're switching it up tonight
switching it up not sponsored not
sponsored yet again
but it is another Waterloo going with
the lemon lime flavor tonight
the lemon lime flavor there you go
not my favorite
but it's but it's in my top
probably my top
four
number one is definitely the peach
for some reason we can hardly ever find
the peach that's probably why it's
probably everybody's favorite one
and then I like the black cherry a lot
that's usually what you guys see me
drinking on stream
but tonight you know what I was like I'm
gonna switch it up I'm gonna go with the
lemon lime
everyone must drink at least one drink
adult apple juice no no this is uh it's
like um carbonated water basically
so it's designed to have that sort of
oh what's the word like that not pop but
that kind of strong
strong Taste of like a soda the strong
carbonation of a soda but it's just
water
really like the Target brand
what is the Target brand it's not
Waterloo is it I had I used to drink
Lacroix and then that one kind of had
like a weird aftertaste
CJ what's up you haven't missed much at
all
you have not missed much at all we've
just been here hanging out welcoming
everyone to the stream trying to get
stream elements to work trying to mod a
new person
and I think everything finally started
working that is so weird though about
the stream elements thing
Nico I don't know if you or anybody else
knows like what would be the cause of
that because I actually went in and I
think the uh
I think it should be correct
the Discord link should now be correct
with exclamation point disc
exclamation point Discord should now be
correct
but then there are some that just
straight up don't work in YouTube
and I think that's more of a
excuse me I think that's more of a
YouTube and stream elements issue
let me try it here I should have one for
exclamation point viewers
see if that works
yeah see it doesn't work there are
currently blank watching the Stream
lower case Logan my friend Happy
Birthday wait it's noobs birthday no way
hope you're having a great day dude and
hey retro LOL also shout out to Logan
we've got like
there's three Logans that usually hang
out in the Stream lower case Logan thank
you so much for the love and support
with the five dollar Super Chat
oh ninja go ninja go go ninja go ninja
go just saw that name in the chat I love
your name Chase Productions one you
never said my name what is what is your
name is it Chase
I'm sorry
it's just it's just
YouTube man YouTube it's not working
right I blame YouTube guys
no see that's the disadvantage of if I
go in alphabetical order then some
people just if they pop in after I start
then it doesn't like Apollo gaming
what's up I see you there better World
Allen c873
but then again these also could just be
people trying to lurk who are like you
know what I don't want you shouting out
my name please
so you know we might just have to go
back to the old way but then I get way
behind
I'm pretty uh I'm pretty close
to being caught up tonight
but if it's seriously uh noob's birthday
happy birthday my friend
and Noob right as we Noob it's your
birthday come on you're not supposed to
you're supposed to be getting the gifts
today my friend
welcome Chase Productions one can't
believe retro forgot you also remember
to hydrate and niffler is life don't you
love that niffler
I love the niffler I actually have two
versions of the niffler I wonder if any
of you have caught this yet
for any of you in the Discord
the niffler that I used in the Discord
is slightly different than the one I'm
using on YouTube
and I don't know which one I like better
I'm gonna see if any of you caught it
without going I mean obviously you can
go look if you want but did any of you
catch it without me mentioning it hey
Nico saw it yes exactly dude you nailed
it yeah the one in the Discord has more
coins in the background
whereas the YouTube one is just holding
up a single coin
it might kind of be fun to keep them
different
for some reason whenever I put whenever
I was uploading this one
on YouTube it just looked better with a
single coin
yeah dude I'm loving the Emoji though I
love them and we also have someone in
our Discord who made an emoji for us
which is going to be the very next one
we use it's uh
the herbology professor in Hogwarts
Legacy she's waving so it'll be very
similar to the
to the uh Harry wave emote that we have
right now
so it'll be very similar to this one
right here
you guys like the Discord one better all
right all right
it's very easy to change if we want to
change it Dr sherbet likes the Discord
when better too
Trevor what's up welcome Trevor
Nathan it's all good don't worry about
being late good and gather is the Target
brand okay
I don't think we've ever tried that one
and we shop at Target a lot
red lioness what's up
do you think we'll see a Hogwarts
showcase for Christmas with holiday
decorations so
we got a
we're in an interesting time right now
we're coming up on the end of October
which means they're running out of time
for the fall ASMR I think it's gonna hit
on Halloween that's just my guess I
think it'd be a great time for it
and then we'll start the countdown for
the uh Chandler also said before the end
of the year that we would see
more gameplay
more gameplay
so my guess
is wb's kind of laying low right now
Gotham Knights is getting the big push
right now in PR For Better or Worse
haven't played it not gonna speak to it
I have no idea but I've heard
I've heard some not so good things about
gothamites and I've heard some some okay
solid to even good things about it but I
I think they're letting it kind of have
its time
and then I think they're gonna kick it
back into gear for Hogwarts Legacy here
pretty shortly
pretty shortly we haven't gotten
anything new so far this week and last
week was pretty quiet as well
today uh we only got the news on the
ESRB because they changed it on their
social media and then they also changed
it on the website so
Noob and lowercase Logan both speaking
very positively of Gotham Knight's Gabe
as well Gotham Knights is really good
20 plus hours can't stop well there you
go see you can't always trust what you
hear that's why I said like I haven't
played it I'm not gonna speak on it
but yeah I definitely expect we'll get a
fall I mean the asmrs they've already
done two they're definitely gonna do two
more the question is when I think
Halloween would be a great time to do
the fall one and then a holiday one
right there at the end of December
for uh like a a Christmas themed one
would be perfect
but the gameplay man that's what I can't
wait to see that's what I am
I mean the asmrs are great don't get me
wrong but I I want more gameplay
yeah so I think maybe the the fall ASMR
they'll kind of stick with the dark arts
theme they got going and then when we
get into winter we get the Christmas the
more light the more happy
we'll see the ASMR I mean it could just
have one scene that's kind of the scary
Moody scene and then it cuts to other
scenes that are are a little more bright
Kratos Raptor what is up my friend you
getting ready for uh God of War Ragnarok
what games you guys playing lately we
got we got a couple in here talking
about Gotham Knights how many of you are
ready for God of War
or what else what else you guys playing
I've been replaying God of War I feel
like we I was thinking about that this
week we should start off with a new
segment
where it's like what he been playing
lately
what have you been playing lately chat
I've been replaying God of War 2018 and
let me tell you
it's so good
uh I beat Ratchet and Clank Rift apart
went all the way and got the platinum
trophy those of you saw me on uh who
follow me on Twitter probably saw me
tweeting out about that one and then
also my my eight-year-old son's really
been getting into fortnite
and I'm like I'm not he's way too young
well
let me be careful anytime you start
talking about parenting people get a
little uh
however you want to raise your kids it's
fine
for him I don't think he's at the
maturity level where he's ready for
online games and
the chat that goes in with that don't
think he's ready personally so anytime
he plays fortnite he either is playing
Solo or I'm I I play with him and
honestly it's been a blast it really has
been a blast we've just been doing Duos
every now and then we'll do Team battles
but uh I used to play a ton of fortnight
back when the game first came out I mean
the first three four seasons I had a
group of friends we played every day
probably
or every night rather it was just a
regular thing every night we'd load up
and play fortnite
so I haven't played it in gosh a ton of
Seasons but I still you know the basics
the mechanics they come back to you so
I've been kind of teaching him a lot of
the basics so yeah beat ratchet playing
fortnite with him uh and then yeah God
of War
replaying God of War is what I've been
playing
Assassin's Creed Origins Lego Harry
Potter I heard Lego Harry Potter might
be coming to uh Playstation Plus next
month Nico's cyberpunk and Warhammer
Mario kart tracks I never bought the
expansion for that
speaking of man I gotta send my switch
in for repair
kind of unfortunate Uncharted series
nice let's go
Star Ocean this week completion run of
horizon
waiting for the Golem or it's Gollum
right yeah Gollum Gollum played Red Dead
Redemption 2 for the fourth time
oh my goodness
Nathan enjoying OverWatch RuneScape
Witcher for Christy wait is that the are
you playing the first Witcher are you
talking about Witcher 3
Disney Dreamlight Valley the privateer
Red Hood looks cool
oh Ryan's saying God of War would be the
best game of 2022 Hogwarts Legacy best
game of 2023. man it's gonna be like
god of war and from software
well I guess let's just say Sony Santa
Monica from software I hold both of them
in such high regard
those two going at it for game of year
Elden ring like I know people kind of
got sick of hearing about Elder ring but
for me guys like Elder ring blew All my
expectations away absolutely love that
game platinumed it on PS5 I think it's
incredible I think it lived up to the
hype and then some I think it's gonna be
really difficult to unseat Elden ring as
game of the year however
I feel like the industry as a whole is
always guilty of this sort of like
recency bias thing so if God of War come
if God of War knocks people knocks
people if if God of War blows people out
of the water then I think it'll win just
because of of that recency it's like
fresh on everybody's minds but honestly
like to have those two games in the same
year Elven ring and God of War
incredible man incredible
uh two games oh for 2023 would be
Spider-Man breath of the wild two yeah
that's some tough competition
minigame other than Elder oh Draven any
game other than Elder ring gets Game of
the Year it's wrong well we can't say
for sure
because we haven't played all the games
yet we haven't seen all all 2022 has to
offer but I think God of War is probably
the only real Contender to be honest I
think it's the only thing this year that
could even really come close for me
that's the thing it's different for
everybody right I mean
that's the beauty of gaming they're just
so many different different kinds of
games different styles of games I've
been seeing a lot of people playing that
uh plague
a tail Requiem or a Requiem tail
something like that
the game is the game guide uh I know I'm
scrolling back up in chat instead of
scrolling down in chat Ryan asked is the
game guide available for pre-orders yet
yeah it's available
you can go on at least in the US I've
had it pre-ordered for a while on Amazon
they've kind of changed around the
release date for it though so we don't
know for sure
Mass Effect Legacy Jason man you guys
are all playing some nice games
Uncharted series OverWatch 2.
Dreamlight Valley just got Mass Effect
legendary editions for Jay Rossi
Harry Potter magic awakened dude is that
ever coming out in the U.S it's crazy
how is it not out they
they had that tweet months ago being
like it's soon
and then weeks months have went by
it takes two share and that game is so
fun I haven't played it but I've watched
a lot of it and it looks so fun
it looks so fun
my wife's not a huge gamer but I feel
like
we would have fun playing that together
Ultra Blue playing biomutant
Assassin's Creed Odyssey and Dishonored
oh I love Dishonored go ninja I feel
like Dishonored is one of the more
underrated series of the past
let's see I guess it would be past two
generations right because it was on
because it was it started on PS3 and
then I think Dishonored two I love just
trying to go through that game
completely stealth
absolutely love it
yo expecto go in the house
expect to go what's up my friend two
month membership saying yo and bye smash
the like button have a magical time
tonight retro and chat got a pod to do
hey good luck with the podcast and
always good to hear from me expect to go
hope the podcast goes well
everybody if you're not already checking
out James from expecto go I feel like
most of you here probably already do
why didn't that pop up by the way on
screen stream elements oh my gosh stream
elements taking time off again
oh goodness you guys
extreme elements man dropping the ball
dropping the ball tonight stream
elements
all right well if we see any more alerts
I'll see if they show up because that
one definitely should have showed up but
yeah it also doesn't show up in my uh
foreign
elements and they just like don't play
nicely with each other I honestly I
probably should look to changing back
over to stream labs
I just never really had a problem with
streamlabs and then there was this whole
thing with them and
OBS and OBS was kind of encouraging
people not to use them but now stream
elements or stream labs and OBS are back
on good terms
uh lots of confusion
but I I feel like I've never had this
many problems out of uh streamlabs
Persona 5 Royal
dude I'm ashamed to say like two of my
the biggest games in my backlog
that I absolutely have to make time for
at some point
Red Dead Redemption 2 which somebody
here already mentioned and
um
persona 5.
started both of them
no I would love them but also know what
a huge time commitment both of them are
so
you wrote Hagrid's magical creatures
right probably one of your favorite
rides
Escape from Gringotts and Harry Potter
Forbidden Journey yeah Forbidden Journey
is awesome I haven't ridden the others
yet because they're at the other side I
haven't been there
Pokemon Sword for James nice nice
oh and the chat just did that thing
where it just skipped
darn it
darn it come on
oh Dr sherbet said no offense I hate
fortnite hey I mean
to each his own
gotta War Pokemon Hogwarts for spoken
Marvel midnight Sons we haven't been
playing Hogwarts yet
Kratos
seeing the community on the old uh BO2
Black Ops 2
still scared
okay that might not be Black Ops that
might be something else same Vibes as
Animal Crossing but better
foreign
if you're talking about Animal Crossing
vibes
okay there we go it is working super
chat's working
nice
Odin killer 9 with the dollar 99 Super
Chat Odin killer thank you so much what
is my favorite game ooh I feel like some
of chat has probably heard me say this
before so my favorite game of all time
is The Last of Us
I've kind of rearranged well I haven't
rearranged my room lately but I have
this awesome awesome artwork
from The Last of Us this the winter
scene in that game
yeah it's my favorite game of all time
probably gonna be very hard for anything
to unseat it honestly
for a long time it was Metroid Prime
Metroid Prime still my top three also
still a really big fan of uh Zelda
Ocarina of Time
and then honestly like the more time
goes by
Elden ring and bloodborne
and Dark Souls 1 for that matter are all
three kind of
they're up there in my top five my top
10 range
for sure
Black Falcon the game is Peggy 16 so it
will be on the upper end of Team teen
equates to 12.
and 16th right yeah it's a little bit
different
on their scale on the European scale
and I was kind of looking at it today
most games that are T for teen over here
end up in Peggy 16 like I know I checked
Uncharted I know I checked uh infamous
I know I checked uh there were a couple
more that I checked that are teen over
here and they were Peggy 16 there
but speaking of here it is you guys here
it is so in addition to just the teen
rating we also got this information here
so they tell you why it's rated T for
team fantasy violence
blood mild language use of alcohol
no big surprises here the use of alcohol
one caught me a little bit off guard at
first but then when you think about like
the hog's head and going into the pub
I'm pretty sure butter beer is not I
mean obviously they give it to miners
like crazy in the Harry Potter series
it's non-alcoholic
but we might have some characters I
don't know drinking fire whiskey maybe
some of the older characters we run into
in game
are gonna be drinking some of the other
beverages in the Harry Potter series
but now there's another thing I want to
show you guys on the rating which we do
not have yet here in a second
just gonna get through you guys talking
about the the games here Mass Effect
Andromeda oh you're playing Witcher 3
Christy gotcha
Force Unleash Call of Duty replaying God
of War Jay hey I'm right there with you
Jay
I'm right there with you
oh Logan
you're cutting me deep it's another one
in my backlog it's an I've played a lot
of ghosts of tsushima actually I would
say I'm probably halfway through the
game
I would say roughly halfway through the
game I need to get back and finish it
but at this point I'm like so far
removed from it I feel like I need to
start all over
I feel like I need to start all over
maybe even play the director's cut and
just get the full experience again
for chat
let's see what's Dylan got to say here
if you want some awesome retro rack into
our merch don't hesitate to visit hey
Dylan thank you so much
yeah we've uh we've been slowly adding
new items to the merch store we got a
pretty cool dark arts one pretty cool
Merlin shirt and then there's gonna be
two other
well one is really kind of
more than one we got more coming before
the end of the year though I'll say that
and honestly the the Teespring Link's
kind of wonky so the easiest way to get
to it is if you just go to retrore
contour.com and then click on merch
that'll get you straight to it
retrorecontour.com and then merch
just finished until dawn little
nightmares last was too oh my goodness
Nick you're playing a lot of games on
the God of War New Game Plus
oh Gotham Knights yeah I can't believe
Gotham Knights is 30 FPS on PS5 that was
kind of a big uh
big shocker for everybody I guess it's
only above 30 on um PC I heard even the
Xbox was not able to run it flagtail is
Wild Star days do you like it plague
Tales
all right we're so far behind
all right I'm scrolling I'm catching up
I'm catching up it's not out in the UK
yet either I know magic awakened it's
unreal
Timothy ninja I love it takes two been
playing it with a friend haven't
finished yet
the book gives me massive Genie vibes
wait is that the is that something in it
takes two the book and it takes two
valorant and reading a lot at the moment
nice
Navajo ninja Last of Us 2 and Horizon
forbidden West I need to play forbidden
West
James when you share the name with a
super cool Hogwarts streamer right James
is awesome I love James James and I are
trying to set up a uh both of us want to
have each other on the live each of our
live shows at some point
it's just lining it up man because James
has a regular job he's got the YouTube
and he's got a family and James has got
he's got like a podcast he does uh
some I was watching him the other night
on
oh my gosh on Twitch playing Dungeons
and Dragons James is involved with all
kinds of stuff but we we definitely want
I want to have him on here one night and
he wants to for me to come on
Wizarding Wednesday at some point as
well so we're trying to work it out
three more weeks until Pokemon
oh yeah Avatar is awesome
Last Airbender some of my favorite
television of all time
Chris you're wearing it right now yo
let's go that's awesome thank you
Christy for the support
all right we're just about caught up now
we're just about caught up fetch Quest
playing Dragon Age Inquisition
oh wait you guys are talking about
butterbeer being it is alcoholic what
an alcoholic quality in the books at
least some of the adults are likely
drinking it in Old Pub mugs
oh you're talking about the rating when
he gets I don't know if I could say uh
d-r-u-n-k
probably don't shouldn't say it much on
a live stream
in book four that's right but is it like
I can't imagine that it's super strong I
almost imagine it like root beer or
something
it was different but in uh when Harry
when they first start having butter beer
they're like super young
Dr sherbet with a super chat
yo thank you so much you should try
subnautica it freaks me out oh is that
like a horror underwater
dude
I already don't like horror
but horror underwater
I cannot do
I cannot do I'm terrified of like
gotta be like two percent butter beer
seeing as it's pre-1901 you could right
yeah
you could sell booze to kids
subnautica is amazing
didn't Hermione act like she was Tipsy
in one of the movies at least
I don't remember that
I don't remember that
Channel I recommend Holden Hardman and
they're experiencing avatar for the
first time oh my goodness I can't wait
to show it to my kids
which they're old enough now but I want
to let him get a little bit older so
they'll appreciate it even more
because right now I don't feel like they
would they would enjoy it but I don't
think they would really truly appreciate
it more terror than horror ooh that
might be even worse
might be even worse
I saw somebody ask
um
ooh I like this question
Cal or KO favorite fantasy book series
other than Harry Potter
okay
let me think
foreign
there's a lot there's a lot
so a couple that I like I liked Percy
Jackson
I'm a little bit like older for Percy
Jackson now I I enjoy them but they're
by the end I was kind of just you know
it's good it's good
um another one that I really loved was
the pin dragon series you guys ever read
the pin dragon series pin dragon is
really good
and then a more recent series that I'm
uh that's more um
more adult is
oh my gosh I just lost it Dresden Files
if you if you grew up a fan of Harry
Potter
man Dresden Files are so good
they're so good the first book is like
okay I'm I'm like I liked that it wasn't
like great amazing crazy or anything but
it was good second book kind of the same
it was enough for me to be like okay I'm
intrigued I want to read more second
book again solid then after that
those books just get insane in the best
way possible
in the best way possible
Lord oh yeah Lord I mean Lord of the
Rings Hobbit
I read The Hobbit to my son
probably about a year or so ago
but I absolutely love the uh
Jim Butcher is the author
of the Dresden Files d-r-e-s-d-e-n
CJ with the 9.99 Super Chat CJ thank you
so much for the love and support butter
beer on me stay hydrated I don't have a
butter beer but I will sip the uh
Waterloo I have
and then um oh there was one more I was
gonna say
there was one more I was gonna say
I lost it
I mean there's so many good ones I just
started reading um
so I had never read any Sanderson before
Brandon Sanderson and I just started
reading I read Steelheart
and I was like eh it started off
solid then like the first half of that
book I was just I was kind of bored then
the the latter part gets pretty good but
then I heard you know mistborn is
probably one that he's most famous for
mistborn and then Stormlight Archive and
so I've started mistborn
and I'm loving it so far I'm probably 50
75 pages in so I'm still very early
very early but I'm I'm enjoying it so
far I think I'm gonna like it a lot
better than Steelheart
pin dragon uh yeah DJ Mikhail Rossi yep
that one
foreign
books made for very young audiences
found Harry Potter in the fourth grade
in your life change were you talking
about Magic Tree House I saw somebody
mention Magic Tree House my son and I
read every single Magic Tree House
he loved those books
all right I'm not feeling this song
he loved those books so much
and he's right he's literally read every
single one that's been out and I've read
probably 75 percent of them with him
now he just started reading the uh
oh they're kind of like young books for
young Percy Jackson
um
heroes in training he just started
reading those
oh I just thought of another one
the Bartimaeus trilogy
Bartimaeus Trilogy is so good and I feel
like it's kind of underrated
I don't I don't hear a lot of people
talk about it
[Music]
foreign
oh this is like some new cover art I've
never seen this one
lowercase Logan you've read it and let's
go dude
uh wait are they making a movie for it
oh what
oh it must have it must be old I don't
think I knew about this
[Music]
it's in progress no way
is this legit guys it says 2013 that's
why I was thrown off did they start
making one and then stop Dylan with
another 10 super chat yo Dylan thank you
so much my friend have a great stream
everyone see y'all on the replay Squad
replay Squad Dylan thank you so much
for all the support
have a good night Dylan
I okay I have to know if this is uh if
this is legit or not
I feel like this was something that was
canceled it never happened but it says
in progress right there still in
development like David Tennant
absolutely yes let's go he's gonna be so
good as Bartimaeus
Isaac Hempstead write as Nathaniel John
Mandrake I can see that I can see that
oh it's been so long since I've read it
okay okay okay hold on hold on
for those of you who haven't heard of
this I gotta find maybe just a Goodreads
will be no I want to just like see the
okay here we go the official site
so there's uh the first one is the
Amulet of semar canned I'm probably not
pronouncing it correctly
wait did they make
wait wait wait wait wait wait
I haven't read this one
I thought it was just a trilogy
this came out in 2011. did I miss this
oh and somebody asked my favorite Potter
book it's definitely Hallows
it's Deathly Hallows
and ironically Deathly Hallows is the
one that I've read the least
I need to do a reread of the whole
series but definitely Deathly Hallows I
reread the first six so many times so
many times
a ghost you see that ghost yeah yeah you
got a little uh a witch there in the top
left every now and then too Professor
Abbott
foreign
my little uh my little friend over here
don't mind my friend it's all good
by the way Dylan says by the way there's
a great discussion Channel about book
series everyone is reading on retro
Discord yes
Glee
yeah
yeah
too many great games and books being
talked about I know right
oh I've got so many games I need to
catch up on so many games
I'm so confused by this like I I'm
almost positive it was originally called
the Bartimaeus trilogy
and ptolemy's gate was the last one
okay here we go The Amulet of simarcan
the gollum's eye and Tommy's gate are
set mainly in an alternative present-day
London they follow yeah okay gotcha
these three books have received many
awards all right yeah so these are and
now he's added a fourth one the bar to
me a sequence
is made up of four best-selling novels
featuring the grumpy sarcastic and
resourceful fourth level genie
Bartimaeus
first book was published in 2003 Sirius
has sold more than 6 million copies 36
languages worldwide yeah this one's good
this one's good
but I I have a new book I need to add to
my list I did not even know this was a
thing ring of Solomon
you have them all Dr sherbet haven't
read them yet
hey we Levi we already had uh the other
Levi
lowercase Levi shouting you out earlier
Timothy only read the first book my
sister got really into Harry Potter this
year she asked her to borrow the rest oh
my gosh Timothy you talking about the
Harry Potter books you haven't read all
the Harry Potter books
you're in for a treat
you are in for a treat my friend
Christy reading Harry Potter now on
number three is this your first time
reading them Christy
because if it is oh my goodness what
what I would do to be able to just like
reread those books afresh once again
God it's your first time that's awesome
ring of Solomon was 2010. dude that's
crazy that I completely like I was a I
would consider myself a fan of those
books and just completely missed did not
even know that released
did not even know that released
right careful careful with spoilers
Snape
nothing I'm not gonna say anything about
Snape nothing at all
I feel like most people have probably
seen the movies though even if they
haven't read the read the books but I
could be wrong
I could be wrong
wait Jay Rossi what
what
like to this day you've never finished
it
did you not like how it was going or
something were you were you like
disappointed
oh how could you read the first six and
not finish it
my mind is blowed
got a couple oh this is a good poll
question
this is a good poll question
oh but I don't think we have enough
options
I was gonna say favorite Harry Potter
book
did see and enjoy the film J Rossi dude
it's so much better than the movie
oh the movie messes up so much with
seven
oh they they messed up so much with
seven
all right let's do a poll
how many options can I have one two
three oh we can only have four options
that's weak
all right um let's see
[Music]
geez I'm yawning all of a sudden uh
let's see okay I guess we could just say
have you read
yeah that's gonna be I feel like that's
gonna be overwhelmingly
[Music]
yeah yeah Nathan yeah Deathly Hallows
for me it's my favorite of all of them
all right this is two elevator music
skipping this one
oh wait hold on hold on I think it just
switched to a different playlist I got
to be very careful here
got to be very careful about the
playlists tonight
oh okay let's see because we only got
four options okay favorite Harry Potter
book
so I'll say
I'm gonna make some people mad if I say
philosophers or Sorcerer's Stone we'll
just say
phosphorus stone or Chamber of Secrets
um Prisoner of Azkaban slash Goblet of
Fire
which then would leave Order of the
Phoenix
slash Half Blood Prince
and then Deathly Hallows gets its own
line so I wish I could do more options
you guys but YouTube the YouTube poll
won't let me so we only have four
options so favorite Harry Potter book
uh option one philosopher stone or
Chamber of Secrets option two prisoner
vast commander of Goblet of Fire
option three Order of the Phoenix or
Half Blood Prince and then the last
option is Deathly Hallows
all right let's hear it let's hear it
JP raven fire yo JP what is up
guys by the way congratulations to JP JP
was the winner of our
25 Amazon gift card sweepstakes
Two Poles can you do two pulls
is that possible
I don't know if that's possible
let me let me try
ah no it's not possible
it's not possible
I would have to end this poll first
[Music]
all right so we've got 43 votes already
early returns coming in after oh I'll
tell you what we could do
oh that wouldn't work either though
yes he like this deadly Hallows is
coming in last
right now POA and Goblet of Fire
at 43 but I feel like
I feel like most that's probably POA
although I feel like Goblet of Fire is
kind of an underrated book people didn't
like that movie nearly as much the movie
had a lot of problems like so many of
the movies though did
but Goblet of Fire is a book man I feel
like it's underrated underrated among
fans
[Music]
love Goblet of Fire Goblet of Fire all
about the teen drama very dramatic
can't vote what why can't you vote
oh yeah I forgot to cast my own vote
why will it not let me I can't vote in
my own poll come on
after this we could split it up yeah
it's
not a scientific Bowl there's no way I'm
going to be able to get an accurate
result now
so it's 46 POA and Goblet of Fire 21
philosopher stone or Chamber of Secrets
21 Order of the Phoenix or Half Blood
Prince and then 13 Deathly Hallows I'm
so even even with Deathly Hallows on its
own I'm surprised to see it so low there
I am a little surprised
Sorcerer's Stone is your least favorite
oh they cut out so much and goblet yeah
in the movie goblet
Phantom draws hey hey let's get the
likes to 100.
yeah guys if you're enjoying the stream
here tonight make sure you hit that like
button before you go it helps more
people find it helps stream spread to
more
stret spread to more people uh there was
another thing I said I was going to show
you guys about the ESRB so
there really isn't a lot of Hogwarts
Legacy stuff to talk about if you guys
have any Hogwarts Legacy questions
though put them in the chat we could
definitely talk about them the main
thing we were discussing tonight was the
new um the fact that the T for teen
rating is confirmed not a huge surprise
not a huge surprise at all that's what
I've expected the whole time and I think
most people have expected that some
people were holding out hope for an M
rating but nah I think team T14 is going
to be perfect for this game I think
that's exactly what they needed to hit
now
esrb.org
if you go here
any type Hogwarts Legacy it is not yet
in the system
but once it is in the system
and some might even argue that this
could honestly be a little bit of a
spoiler territory here so let me pick
like an older game uh I'll pick infamous
once they actually have it in the system
here
they're going to give a lot more so here
it is if I click on this right here
they give you a lot more information so
like right now
all we know about Hogwarts Legacy is the
T14 and then we have fantasy violence
blood
mild language uh use of alcohol
or what we have so this was for the
original infamous on Playstation 3. uh
blood drug reference language mild
suggestive themes and violence but then
once it's actually logged into the ESRB
system they're gonna have this full
breakdown here
to where they tell you and most of it is
stuff like this where you get
they actually spell out what what the
profanity is
but then there are some things where you
actually get a little bit
of story a little bit of how the game is
going to play out so like right here so
this is again this is old about Infamous
action adventure game players use
electrical superpowers to subdue Urban
gangs in a post-apocalyptic World
presented from a third person
perspective game allows players to roam
around the open world environment and
electrocute anyone at any time
including civilians and security police
forces while players receive good karma
points for killing gang members they are
penalized with bad karma for attacking
the pedestrians objects and other
neutral parties combat is often frenetic
and includes explosions cries of pain
and Bri I mean they have they have to be
descriptive like this right and brief
blood splashes to indicate damage some
of the more striking imagery is
contained in the comic book panel
cutscenes civilians are seen getting hit
by a barrage of machine gun fire
security prison guards appear Gravely
injured with patches of blood on their
uniforms you guys get the idea
so I don't know how soon
this will be posted they might keep this
under wraps all the way up until launch
so
but I'm gonna try to make a habit of
like checking in on it like let's see if
they've got
like Gotham Knights just came out
okay so Gotham Knights is in here oh
okay I know a good one like let's see if
God of War Ragnarok is in here yet
they probably wait oh no it's in here
okay I'm not gonna read this one
because there could be some spoilers in
here
foreign
but they do already have a rating
summary in for God of War Ragnarok which
is not out yet so I don't know how soon
they put it in there so the fact that we
already had the fact that we do have the
rating confirmed now
what's another game that's not out yet
but that we have the rating for
uh for Europe you guys use the Peggy
system
so it's Peggy 16.
oh no not that
come on where is it I was just looking
at it earlier today too
yeah here you go here it is
so whereas in the US we have T for teen
the Peggy system is kind of uh they have
some a little bit more of a granular
nature to it
so like fortnite and OverWatch they get
hit with just the Peggy 12 rating
whereas Hogwarts Legacy is hit with the
Peggy 16 rating
for the most part though any games that
fall in these two are usually T for teen
here in the U.S
there are no spoilers on there oh good
good good good
because I know there are a lot of them
floating around online right now so I'm
not even gonna
I'm not even gonna attempt it by looking
you can't think of that which is an
actual spider
wait like a like a spider on your screen
oh that's funny
that's too funny
oh Nico
Nico coming in with the ten dollar Super
Chat
I'm waiting for it to pop up on screen
dude
stream elements they're slacking tonight
guys they're slacking like some of the
okay there it is
I I was way ahead of you stream elements
Nico thank you so much for your support
of the stream if you want more retro in
your life make sure to check out his
Twitter and his newsletter you can find
that here yo thank you so much Nico we
have been doing the newsletter every
week but I think every month might be a
better uh
a better approach for that
but we'll see I mean whenever we have
things to talk about it could be every
week
but yeah thank you so much for uh not
only donating but choosing to plug
more of our
more of our online presence with your
donation Nico thank you so much
oh we were just talking about the rating
Ryan for uh oh you mean God of War so
God of Wars it's definitely here
God of War is definitely in the 18
category
I wonder if this is actually I don't
think this is actually the Peggy site
though
but there is a site they do officially
have a site
well it might be this one right here
yeah yeah so
let's see if they have Ragnarok in there
yet
so it looks like they
do not have Ragnarok in their system
just yet
but here's the one for uh so they're all
18. all the God of War games have been
18.
[Music]
ah okay that's good to know
Caesar that's good to know
because I was afraid that Infamous one
was just oddly descriptive maybe they
updated over time
like maybe before the game comes out
they limit it to
being what
I don't know they're not they wouldn't
they wouldn't only do what the pr folks
give them though but maybe they do be
like okay we won't spoil the game until
after it's out and then we'll put things
that are more descriptive
Ultra Blue I remember the post for
months ago that we will be able to hone
our skills anywhere in the world
[Music]
um
hone your skills anywhere in the world
I'm not following you on that one
does that mean we can practice spells
potions when we want
uh I think potions are going to be tied
to
stream elements bot running now now like
oh what is going on with the stream
alone spot tonight
it's back everybody it's back uh no I
think potions are going to be tied to
are you
are you actually running or not
I think potions are going to be reserved
for the room of requirement
in that little station that we see
and I think practicing spells will be
reserved for the
that little area that we see just
outside of the kind of like behind the
gamekeepers hut
wait what are you guys talking about
tomato juice what did I miss here did
somebody get sprayed by a skunk or
something
laughs
hold on I'm scrolling back up Nathan
did Nathan get
oh
Nathan's dog got sprayed by a skunk
today and the entire house Reese what do
I do yo L one is Elwyn in the house
is Elwyn in the chat we have a dog
question in the chat
Elven would be the perfect person to
answer this some people are saying
baking soda I always heard tomato juice
too but now I see a lot of people say
not tomato juice
oh yikes I have no idea though
if elwin pops back in we'll have to ask
elwin Ellen's a dog trainer you guys so
I bet Elwyn would know feathers what's
up welcome feathers wow not YouTube
deleting my whole comment except for the
emoji wait what
I see you're not tomato juice and I see
you're baking soda comment
but nothing else
a skunk soap at Walmart or a deskunk
soap at Walmart and helped out a lot
Ryan who is annoyed with God or Ragnarok
people have been able to play five hours
of the game
dude I should have requested an early
copy why didn't I think of that
people have pre-ordered still have to
wait I mean that's that's long been an
industry thing
it's just
honestly it helps out the the people who
are
writing and making videos like we talked
about this a little bit with Hogwarts
Legacy I was talking to uh Andy reloads
about this
and if you like if we were to get early
access to the game
even just even like a week out which
these God of War reviewers are getting
what like a not quite a full month but
quite a bit of time to play this game
that would help us so much
that would help us so much because see
what happens is on YouTube it's so
important to be well I shouldn't say
it's so important in some cases it's
important to be Timely
right like
there are certain Hogwarts Legacy videos
that will just not do well
two or three months into launch you need
to be that first week first month you
need to have those those videos out
and so if you don't get Early Access
time to play the game early then
that is a ton of work
for us
basically from the get-go as soon as the
game comes out excuse me when people
immediately start looking for
information so if I if I was to get an
early copy that would only help me
get better quality videos out so that
way as soon as the Hogwart as soon as
the game releases
you guys would be able to see my
spoiler-free thoughts like day one or
whenever the Embargo goes up day one I'm
gonna have videos on tips ready to roll
you know those wouldn't go out day one
because you want to wait till people
play the game for a bit
um but it would yeah it would just be a
huge help so that's why they do it
now you could argue games like
God of War I mean well I was gonna say
they don't really need the promotion and
they don't really need much promotion
but I do think it's it really helps out
the content creators out there so I do I
do get it
from that perspective
I definitely get it
you added someone and it deleted hold on
I'm trying to read Phantom's comment
here
it deleted the whole thing except for
the
okay well it could be two things fandom
it could be stream elements bot
there are certain words that are flagged
and sometimes stream elements bot
misinterprets things
or one thing I've seen that gets caught
a lot is when people put
um they type a sentence put a period and
then don't put a space after it's just
like a typo but YouTube and or stream
elements detect it as a link
and so it won't allow it to be posted
so just make sure you're putting up a
period after a space after the period
and then as long as there's no bad
language in there it should work fine
Professor Abbott I'm gonna have to ask
for early Hogwarts access
yeah I'm trying to find like who to ask
I've reached out to some people but
haven't heard anything so I hope I hope
we do man I hope
I mean you think about guys like Andy
and myself and
um
I mean all the Hogwarts I guess the
YouTubers James expect to go we're not
like in a lot of the developers eyes
were not huge like we're not big
channels so they might just they might
just give them to the igns of the world
to the Game Stops of the world to the
I don't know pick your big million plus
YouTuber they might just have them for
them I don't know I have no idea
um I know Andy has done a little bit of
work with some developers and he said
it's kind of hit or miss that some of
them
are like totally cool with sending out
codes they don't even really care how
big the channels are
and then others like you just don't hear
anything from them so
we'll see man we will see I would I
would love I'm not expecting it but I
would love it if it happened
so
if you're 12 can you still play Hogwarts
Legacy
um that's question for your parents
yeah so I don't know how it works in the
UK and and in Europe but it but in the
US
they check your your age
where you can buy a game but really they
only they only care about t for team or
I'm sorry M for mature
T14 I don't think they really care and I
don't think they really check
yeah I don't know how exactly it works
over there
but over here to buy an M rated game you
have to to show ID but Hogwarts Legacy
won't have to worry about that
foreign
I would say ask your parents
illegal like legality I have no idea I
have no idea in terms of legality I am
not giving legal advice on this channel
thing embargo lifts a week before launch
for God of War yeah they usually kind of
do staggered rollouts like so far they
lifted the Embargo for the first five
hours or whatever
they're allowing clips and images of
game of scenes which aren't in the
trailer and then yeah then you have
people who like ruin everything and
spoil which is what has happened with
God of War sadly
so be careful stay away stay away
oh yeah thank you Professor Abbott yeah
yeah it's not it's not even about the
quality I think it's just more of an
sometimes we wonder on our end you know
is it a numbers game like do they just
look for numbers and say oh well
this Channel's over this much so we're
not going to give them a code I I have
no idea I have no idea how it works for
companies
I know it's I know it's different for
different companies like sometimes
in terms of sponsorship and everything
in some cases people actually prefer
smaller audiences because it's even more
targeted if that makes sense like
you can really focus in on the audience
that like you're trying to appeal to
Phantom draws this is a test
we should all hop on Twitter oh no don't
you don't have to do that CJ you know
well I mean to be clear like nobody said
no like nobody's we just don't know and
we're still so far out at this point
they wouldn't have even talked about
this but I mean you guys have seen like
Chandler responds to a lot of us
so I mean Chandler is definitely aware
of aware of most of us the Hogwarts
Legacy YouTube YouTubers
so I think if it's I think if it's up to
Chandler if Chandler has any ability or
power to do it I think we would get one
I do
but that's where like WB comes in like I
don't know how much it's
like where does WB
because I feel like they're the ones in
charge of the codes and I have I have
been trying to reach out to a couple of
different wbpr contacts just to like
establish a general like hey where do I
sign up for press releases that sort of
thing and I can't get a response from
anybody they for you for the UK
Andy sent me a site they have a whole
dedicated website where you can sign up
and you get all their releases and and
um
footage and stuff like that they send to
you
but I can't find a US equivalent so
I don't know I'm gonna keep trying
I'm Bar Twitter no no no
no no I don't we don't need to bombard
anybody
but as we get closer I think
I will definitely ask
I will definitely ask and report back
what I hear
if anything Chandler would at least know
like Chandler would be able to tell me
yeah it's not gonna happen or yeah I
think you guys probably will
oh Elwood just came back oh elwin we
have people we have a dog question for
you Elwyn
that's another good point feathers yeah
they could go for like it's a numbers
game right like they they probably know
that the vast majority of
my audience is buying this game already
they probably know that
I don't think they'll be stingy with
review copies
[Music]
I thought chat would put the question
but they didn't put the question out
Owen so uh someone's dog was sprayed by
a skunk
and they were asking what is the best
way to clean and get rid of the smell
some people were saying tomato juice
some people were saying baking soda some
people were saying no not tomato juice
so I'm like
I bet Elwyn might know the answer to
this
Ellen might know the answer
hey Krista I work in a library as well
that's awesome
yeah we don't have we used to have games
at our library
and libraries in general are very sort
of I mean we're very anti-censorship so
we we put a lot on
we put the responsibility on the parent
and so I don't as far as I know I think
we're kind of the same Krista I don't
think we would restrict any sort of
like I think a kid could check out any
book they want
and it's sort of on the parent to be
aware of you know to monitor that
I think I think
hey Jenna how's it going yeah T14
confirmed
Phantom if you had done one more message
it would have done
have you figured it out Nico have you
figured out what the exact number is
oh wait hold on I'm scrolling back up
here I want to see elwin's response
dog got sprayed by a skunk what's oh
yeah here we go
do not get it wet okay
Wanda says what I'd like is him letting
us all at least preview character
creation
and like in uh in that Disney game let
us import our pre-made characters into
the game when it releases
oh that's an interesting idea
interesting idea now they did just on
the Wizarding World website we did this
last time
you guys didn't see this on the official
Wizarding World site they have this new
I don't know little mini game feature
whatever you want to call it where you
can actually create your own what do
they call it your own Wizarding World
Avatar with our new portrait maker
it's pretty fun actually
so a lot of people were saying hey
wouldn't it be cool if that came over
into the game
I don't know I like I don't feel like
the art style matches up but this was
fun I did enjoy doing this
Noob said get a new dog oh my gosh
that's just wrong
that is just wrong
[Music]
wait Owen answered I saw the do not get
it wet
first thing that you do not want to get
the dog wet initially that will open the
pores of the hair and the stink will be
in there forever oh yikes I don't know
if we're that soon or if uh they've
already tried to
to get rid of it
let's hope you're not too late exactly
we waited about two hours before using
the D skunk soap on her and it just made
a big difference ah gotcha
already rescued her from a shelter nice
try oh that's awesome Nathan
that's awesome
use a mix of hydrogen peroxide baking
okay somebody said uh baking soda
get that on your dog ASAP get it worked
into the fur as much as possible and let
it sit for 10 to 15 minutes see I told
you guys Helen would know about this
once it worked in and you have let it
sit then and only then should you wash
them off there you go
somebody gave that mixture earlier I
thought I remembered seeing that yeah I
knew I I saw somebody mention baking
soda
thank you elwin thank you
little pit turned two yesterday oh nice
now what if a human gets sprayed
Elwyn is a dog trainer you guys not a
human trainer
oh goodness
all right hold on I saw a question back
up here that I wanted to answer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay there we go I read that one
oh there it is king of games three
that's the one I wanted to talk about
have you seen the Australian rating it
says online activity
I saw podcast now's video talking about
this
my and it also says in-game purchases
my guess is that it is just talking
about the
um
the fact that you can buy the deluxe
pack
even if you buy the regular version
that's that's my guess
I don't think there's any sort of hidden
online mode that it's hinting at I don't
I mean it'd be awesome if there if there
was but
yeah so for those of you haven't seen
this the um Australian video game rating
let's see if we can find this Australian
video game rating I don't know what the
name of their
ratings board is
okay let's see if they have Hogwarts on
the site yet yes they do
nice
okay Hogwarts Legacy PlayStation 5.
foreign
so yeah again they have a very different
so don't think m
like our m in the US
their classification is M for moderate
impact
and it is rated this for Supernatural
themes violence online interactivity and
in-game purchases
so I think it's just simply talking
about the uh
the the it's not even really I mean I
guess it is DLC downloadable by
definition it's downloadable content my
guess is that's what they're talking
about for the online interactivity
it could be uh the linking of your
Wizarding World account that's a
possibility
or it could simply be talking about the
possibility that you need to connect for
a Day One update
like let's see let's see what they have
for
I want to see what if they have this for
other games
God of War Ragnarok really not in there
yet
okay here we go God of War
multi-platform
well that's definitely not the right one
rated G
Ator games
wrong God of War
we're all got over It's gotta be this
one
I'm just looking to see if there are
other any other games that
have that online interactivity
okay not on that one
uh let's see
heading out Phantom draws hey have a
good one thanks so much for stopping by
that's my guess for the in-game purchase
however I think the online mode is for
the dark arts Arena unless that was
proven wrong
so here's
I feel like Chandler's answered this a
lot
I just I really think they're trying to
drive home unless they're just wanting
to completely surprise us
[Music]
I mean there's that one and then here's
the in-game purchases
players with the standard edition can
purchase the dark arts pack in game
separately which is otherwise available
exclusively in the deluxe edition there
are no other items for purchase in the
game
now maybe down the road
but they that sounds pretty definitive
right there and then here you go right
here does Hogwarts Legacy have online or
co-op gameplay Hogwarts Legacy is a
single player experience and does not
have online or co-op gameplay
so I feel like that's pretty clear
I feel like that one's pretty clear
uh Logan says online interactivity could
just be talked about the ability to link
the fan yeah yeah yep podcast now talked
about that in his video and I kind of
think the same thing
what are we doing in the dark arts Arena
so
I think dark arts Arena
is going to be like a
training area
I'm still kind of working out exactly
what I what I what I think it's gonna be
some sort of training area
where you can
practice spells
but I think it could also end up being
the
that dueling club that they hinted at
so confused
oh Alicia yeah what are we doing in the
dark arts Arena yeah that's kind of my
thought
assuming it's a stage for the dueling
Club yeah
place we could test combos against
various NPCs training challenge Arena
yeah
yep that's where I'm at that's what I'm
thinking too
that's exactly what I'm thinking
who is texting me at this hour what in
the world
oh yeah I was having to
by the way Nintendo's customer support
is uh awesome that you can chat with him
I was telling chat earlier and I got
completely sidetracked
so my switch
the left you know the joy-cons have
always been kind of a big a big issue
they're they're faulty and they they go
bad very easily so joy-con drift they
have they've had all kinds of issues
with these joy-cons but also from the
snapping like when it snaps into the
system
so before a couple years ago I had a
problem with a joy-con it wasn't being
detected by the system
here
or no it may have been joy-con drift or
may have been both I can't remember but
whatever it was sent in the joy-con they
fixed it no problems Chrissy heading out
Chrissy thanks so much have a good night
Christy thank you for being here
now my new problem is the joy-con's not
being detected so my my kids or I will
be playing for a while and then out of
nowhere it'll think that the joy-con has
been disconnected so I thought okay
maybe it's maybe it's a joy-con so
Got a Brand New joy-con
same problem
so I go online read Nintendo's
troubleshooting they're talking about
you know make sure you've updated the
system software did you turn it off and
turn it back on yes I tried all these
things
I tried all these things I even uh I
took like a little Q-tip with alcohol
and cleaned all in there
took a can of compressed air sprayed it
all out and it worked for like half a
day
and then it started doing the same thing
again just if you kind of like shift
that left joy-con around a little bit
becomes disconnected
so yeah I'm gonna have to send it in so
they were I was texting them earlier I
was like what is this text that's
popping up here at this hour
Luna Comics kind of wish there was a
multiplayer so I can make friends online
oh well already have friends IRL can do
single player yeah that's uh that was
kind of a big
topic of
great Division and debate among fans
before they confirmed it I'm in the camp
that I think would be awesome as a
separate add-on thing much in the way
that ghost of tsushima did it not
affecting the single player experience
not something that's required
because you're right there's so many of
us who want a a bit more of a social
experience something that we can do
together something we can hop on with
friends
and play and it just I mean Hogwarts
Legacy isn't that kind of game they're
doubling down they're they're just I
mean it's like it's something like The
Witcher it's something like the Elder
Scrolls Skyrim not not Elder Scrolls
Online it's Elder Scrolls Skyrim instead
so
that's what they're doubling down on and
I mean on one hand I really do I
appreciate the focus from them I do I
appreciate that they're saying this is
what we're making like this is what
we're focusing on
and who knows I mean I know Andy is
thinking even though they're saying this
Andy thinks that at some point maybe
they still might down the road
I definitely think it would be
successful I do if they ever decided to
do it
but then at the same time it's like
wouldn't you rather have just a second
game you know more story stuff
yeah it goes to sushima did it very well
it didn't it didn't affect the single
player experience at all you you still
got a complete game
and then they dropped it for free out of
nowhere when nobody expected it
Torchlight two I haven't played those L1
Torchlight two and three did it pretty
well enhances the experience
not needed in order to play zodiac
what's up miss anything big nah not so
much not too much going on tonight
we got a t for T rating confirmed from
Hogwarts Legacy the official website has
confirmed that but that's really all the
news that we have
gonna check their Twitter just make sure
they haven't uh so they updated it here
rated T for teen
but then yeah they they haven't been uh
it's been kind of a quiet week so far
and and last week was was pretty quiet
as well
so I was kind of speculating earlier I
think they're going to lay low for a
little bit until Gotham Knights has its
you know couple weeks of coverage
and then I would expect I think
Halloween I think they gotta do
something on Halloween I'm leaning
toward a fall ASMR
as my guess Jake you're heading out Jake
thank you so much for stopping it by
hanging out and showing the love and
support as always Jake
have a good one
do we know the full size of the map
Katrina uh
pretty close from
wife once a wizard did a map
and there have been some other videos
online looking at kind of how big the
map will be
uh it's it's big it's big
it should be a pretty big game
they did multiplayer for Mass Effect 3
Dragon Age 3 the same didn't affect the
game at large right right right
I jinxed it last week what did I say
last week that we've been getting so
much honestly like I
I'm okay with the time with a little bit
of time to catch our breath
I am I I feel like things have just been
flying by you guys it's gonna be here I
know we've been waiting so long but it's
gonna be here before you know it
it's gonna be here before you know it
and just
trust me I think I think it was James
expect to go I think there was somebody
I heard talking about this
and I couldn't agree more like enjoy
this time of anticipation
because it'll like there there will
never be another time like this like
maybe a sequel comes out and we get to
have this sort of thing again again
but since the the release of the books
man this is like as close as I've been
able to get to that feeling again
leading up to it to a book so for those
of you who who read the Potter series
growing up you know what I'm talking
about
like the time between books was some of
the most fun because you had so much
speculation
you had so many theories and discussions
and like that was when that was when
internet message boards were really
taking off my first ever podcast I'm
gonna show my age here you guys that my
first ever podcast was
um my car at the time it had a CD player
but it didn't have any sort of MP3 any
sort of um
oh what's the the auxiliary connector it
didn't have any of that no Bluetooth
nothing
so the the first couple podcasts I ever
listened to was muggle cast and I would
burn the CD
in my college dorm room I would burn the
CD of
an episode or two sometimes I could fit
two episodes of mugglecast and listen to
the
listen to those CDs until then I had a
my dad had an iPod Shuffle that he
didn't want he gave it to me and so then
I started using that to listen to them
Logan talking about mugglecast right
there
yeah like that anticipation man like I
admit one thing I miss more than
anything
and I don't know that we'll ever see
anything like this again
and for the for the younger ones out
there I'm sad you all won't get to
experience this because
the way that our culture is moving
everything is is Shifting more towards
digital
and
the midnight launch parties
were just something special man they
were they were something special
and I don't know man like I I get sad
thinking about it because I'm like there
needs to be there needs to be more
things like that out there
even if it's not Harry Potter
something and so now it's like I mean
yeah like let's say new stranger things
season whatever that it's it's online
you know we don't we don't go anywhere
and hang out as a group
um
new video games now you you pre-load
them onto your system download them at
midnight they're ready to go
or or you have them show up at your
doorstep I mean it's just it's just
weird I feel like they're and in a lot
of ways it's all more convenient but
there are some things that are just like
uh
I miss I really do
leaky cauldron oh yes Elwyn I have some
pictures of uh
I went to one of the live
Potter cast episodes in their their
summer of seven tour
they went to so many different cities
and I went to one of the live shows I
actually won
at all their live shows they would do a
spell game
or a lot of their live shows they would
do a spell game where uh when I when I
did it they had us in pair so it was
like two versus two so it was me and
another I can't remember if she was also
a Gryffindor or if she was a Ravenclaw
but it was like two on Two And so you
play it was like the dueling game so we
would duel but it was like how many
spells could you recall from memory so I
got picked me and this lady go up there
and we won but it was um you just like
go back and forth how many spells you
can name and you can't name the same one
twice
but stuff like that dude it was so fun
so much fun and so I feel like that like
this this weekly conversation
this is all part of that it's part of
the lead up and
once the game's out yeah it'll be
awesome
and hopefully they'll announce a sequel
and we'll get to do all this over again
but just make sure you stop
and enjoy this time too make sure you
make sure you uh appreciate all of this
as well
I know how you feel the anticipation
relating to the books well said hey
thanks Bradley yeah
Noob says it'll probably fly by I forget
what data was a few days next thing it's
your birthday
the hints the clues oh my gosh right on
JK Rowling's website yes
and the release of the the book Seven
title because we didn't know the title
for a while and there was this little
game
JK Rowling's old website was awesome in
the lead up to Harry Potter there were
all these little clues that would be
hidden on there and whenever the door
would open like the door would have a do
not disturb
sign on it but whenever the do not
disturb sign disappeared
you all everybody knew like oh my gosh
there's a way to unlock this door and it
was always something you had to do on
screen something you had to interact
with to get that door open
oh you're taking me back elwin man so
many good memories
and then uh the muggleneck guys they put
out the book who lives who dies Who
falls in love and how the story finally
ends or something like that it was like
a book of predictions
and then Melissa anelli of the Leaky
cauldron wrote a book called Harry a
history which is kind of a fun look back
at the fandom if you ever want to relive
some of that
man oh I'm getting so nostalgic
it's so sad that it's all all done
always released in the summer which is
your birthday oh yeah the parties they
were so fun
write movies too Jay Rossi yeah movies
have kind of
they're in an interesting spot too that
was I think spurred on even more as a
result of the pandemic
but yeah like movies I I did a couple
midnight launches for movies and those
were fun too but
like having that many people show up for
the launch of a book
that was that was something truly epic
that was something truly epic
and I'll never forget one of them was on
I was on vacation with my she was my
girlfriend at the time now my wife but
we were
I think it was the last night before we
came back home for vacation with her it
was uh we were with her family
and she had never bit I don't think
she'd even read the books at that point
I'm trying to remember because at some
point I got her to read
I finally convinced her to read the
books and she loved them of course
but I can't remember I don't think she
had read them yet at that point
but I took her with me like she went
with me and I was like you just don't
know
you just don't know how epic this is
gonna be
she was not prepared
the one we went to it was uh for book
six is release and they had like they
had partnered up with the zoo and they
had animals in there
all sorts of Harry Potter themed snacks
and beverages
are they really doing a reread right now
Logan oh my gosh is it like it's not the
old school crew though right is it a new
uh is it a new crew
all right let me see how many of the
original
so I originally started out with muggle
knit with mugglecast and then I found
Potter cast and they kind of became my
main one
but I still love mugglecast too
dude when I first started listening I
want to see how many of the guys I can
name Andrew Sims obviously Andrew was
like the main host
um Ben Shane Eric skull
there was uh Laura oh what was her name
Laura
what was Laura's last name
oh I can't remember Laura's last name
but it was mostly guys on muggle on
mugglecast
and then on pottercast it was Melissa
John and Sue and then sue eventually
left and they added frack
oh such so many good episodes of those
shows but yeah I haven't listened to
them in years I have stopped listening
the whole uh
drama around the author just
just too much just too much with all the
uh author drama
it's sad you know regardless of how you
feel about that whole
debate uh it definitely ripped the
fandom that's for sure
that's for sure
but fortunately we can all still you
know
we can all still together and appreciate
the series
for what it is and especially with
something like Hogwarts Legacy
all right hold on I'm catching up on
these comments now
I can't believe they're doing a chapter
by chapter now though that's awesome
movie midnight releases AKA Avengers
endgame so jealous that would have been
great oh it was so good it was so fun
like I know they probably didn't feel
like celebrities at all but I was a bit
Starstruck they felt like celebrities to
me
like at that point Melissa had
I think that's after she had she had met
JK Rowling at that point it's like you
you've been in the presence of Jay you
were in JK Rowling's home I think she
actually got to interview her at her
house
before book seven or something
I knew I've been going to a game store
playing Yu-Gi-Oh card games for a while
just Speedy people there that have the
same sort of interest is amazing
retro shows up in his spell shirt right
to play the Spells game no that shirt
didn't exist back then actually I I did
wear a Gryffindor shirt though
I did wear a Gryffindor shirt
Nico I would have dominated that game
ill when I already sense a sassy
response no I would have won
The Unofficial mystery guide to Harry
Potter was awesome was that the Muggle
net
the mugglenet book
foreign
you weren't allowed to read the books
yeah I mean I'm uh I don't like to say
I'm religious because that word has so
many negative connotations but I am my
Faith's very very important to me and
always has been I'm you know I'm a
person of faith and growing up
my mom initially was like
because you know there was that time
where it kind of caught I mean it just
like went crazy everybody was talking
about it from all different angles like
just the phenomenon and then there were
part there were some people like hey you
know is this promoting witchcraft the
whole Banning of books thing which is
kind of
coming back it's funny how the banned
books thing man
and working at a library we deal with
this a lot but like
it's like it's all sides all all
political sides are affected by this and
a lot of times they don't even know that
all the sides are
like right now any books with um
like like gender identity that sort of
thing those are among the most
challenged but then you also have books
like the Bible that are among the most
challenged you have
um To Kill a Mockingbird
some of the most challenged
so it's like people can find any little
thing and and technically they're not
even banned that was that was a phrase
chosen by libraries years ago to
basically say that you know if you if
you have them removed from libraries yes
people could still buy them but they are
effectively banned because
that is preventing a certain certain
groups of people from being able to
check out the books because they can't
afford to buy them
but anyway
um your comment Logan got me thinking
yeah and so my mom like I grew up in a
in a very religious home and so they
were she's like
okay I'm gonna check this out but my
mom's a big reader so she read them and
she was like oh my gosh this is crazy
these are awesome she loved though she
thought they were great so she didn't
have any problem at all
but yeah that that whole oh man the
whole over that was just way way
overblown way overblown
which again like looking back on it now
I don't really think it was as big of a
deal like in terms of the the band Harry
Potter stuff I feel like it was just a
few a very loud very loud minority of
people
very loud small small minority I feel
like
but because they're so loud it affects
you know a lot of parents are like what
you know I don't want my kid reading it
promotes witchcraft are you kidding me
top 10 regrets oh no don't
you ready finally hey you still got to
experience them when you were 18.
but yeah I I wish you know
I'm glad my mom took the time to just be
like okay I'm gonna read this
and see what it's all about first
but yeah she uh she loved them too she
absolutely loved him
for me the books just breed so much life
into the world like the Order of the
Phoenix movie versus oh yeah
I mean I try not to knock on the movies
too much because I I appreciate them for
what they did in terms of bringing Harry
Potter even more to the mainstream which
they did I admit that they did they get
a lot more people interested in the
series which is awesome
and in some way like I do feel like they
captured the spirit I Gotta Give Them
credit for that they captured the spirit
but then there are so many areas where
they they missed they just they just
missed the mark
and I have to almost consider it not a
separate series but I mean it's a
separate interpretation in my head like
that's that is one one version of the
story of the story of Harry Potter and
then there's the version that's in the
books which
that is my primary version
that is my primary version
right now it's Laura T Micah Micah
Micah tan and Bam or Tannenbaum dude
Michael had a broadcasting voice from I
don't know how old he was when he first
started but he he had a broadcasting
voice ready to go from the beginning I
can't believe that it's a lot of the
same crew though that's crazy
I'm gonna have to check it out sometime
if they're doing a reread
so cool he said he didn't get to read
them sooner yeah
and an oh Potter cast up up until a few
years ago they were still doing it too
but
like I said I stopped listening to a lot
of them around the time the whole uh
stuff around the author started blowing
up I just
that's just not why I listen man that's
just not why I listen
and I I know it was like it was
definitely a topic of discussion at that
time and had to be discussed but
I'm just I'm just there for the uh you
know I want to talk about the characters
I want to talk about the world
Krista exactly it really is interesting
to look at throughout throughout history
and see how things
how it how it has affected pretty much
wherever you fall on the political
Spectrum wherever you fall on the
religious Spectrum
books that you support have probably
been challenged by someone at some point
comment about Dementors
I did not see a comment about the
mentors
hold on that was from Ryan let's see if
I can find it
oh my gosh so many comments
was it a while ago Ryan
and I realize I'm behind now too see
this is what happens
this is what happens I start I start
talking
oh my gosh did somebody just get spoiled
did somebody just get
s uh yes r r bolect i I follow the
teachings of of Christ I do I do not
like to say even the word Christian
contains so many negative connotations
nowadays
because a lot of people
they know they knew a Christian one time
who treated them a certain way but it's
not in reality
what Christ would teach or what Christ
taught so that's why I kind of hesitate
even on that word
my mother could never get into books or
understand how people could get so into
them when Sirius um
you know when something happened to
sirius in order of the Phoenix
I bawled my eyes out in the living room
and she thought I was physically hurt
yeah there
the Potter books are an emotional roller
coaster they are
I think
I'm trying to think
it takes a lot for me to cry it really
does in in books or movies
it's it's very rare very very very rare
I got I got teary-eyed at the end of
Return of the King
might be it
in terms of movies and then reading the
Potter books I got teary-eyed
close your ears if you haven't seen or
if you haven't seen the seventh movie or
read the seventh book close your ears
for about 15 seconds
don't want to spoil anybody apparently
we had some people earlier Elwyn who
were saying they hadn't they were
reading the books and had never read
them
so I don't know if they were joking
about the serious comment or not but
come on guys it's been how many years at
this point
but um
the Dobby one Dobby one got me pretty
teary-eyed too in book seven
that one got me
but yeah just in terms of like
straight up balling it takes it takes a
lot oh my gosh a more recent movie that
Coco got me pretty close and then I was
watching um
onward
which as a father to two boys
if you've seen that movie I mean it's
not the best Pixar movie but I will I
will forever love that movie because I'm
a dad to two boys and just oh
so many so many parts of that movie
oh man they just they they they get you
right in the heart
right in the heart on that movie
your cousin used to think you were a
real wizard because of the books had
candles in my room and he assumed
too good Theo too good
I know it's sad there's not an actual
Hogwarts though it is sad
Ravenclaw Tyrell also wasn't allowed to
read or watch wow so we have we've had
several people say that
once I watch the movies like okay I need
to read them and right like in terms of
like the degrees of problematic content
out there
Harry Potter is like low low low on the
totem pole there was a book that
somebody wrote I actually wrote a paper
in uh
High School
I'm pretty sure I've told you guys this
before
but we're kind of on this topic tonight
so I'll go with it
I wrote a paper in high school called
Don't ban Harry Potter
you know I was like going through the
books talking about all the you know the
positive lessons
and how it's a world of fiction
which some people apparently like I
don't know
think it's a book of spells for
transfiguring your friend or something I
don't know back then at least
but uh but yeah so
and there was a book called Finding God
in Harry Potter
so yeah there was a lot of good uh
references at that time to pull from I
could just picture Harry Potter done as
an anime movie I would watch you could
go into depth hey I would love that
Slytherin some people hate that idea I
would love
animated movies or even a show an
animated show I think would be great
at this point I would almost rather them
have a a show
than more movies
because we've just seen so so many good
adaptations lately
in terms of shows
um the first five seasons of of Game of
Thrones were pretty solid
and see Potter would have the advantage
of everything's out everything's done
they have all the material they need
and I feel like a show
would really give you the ability to to
flesh it out now there's been
speculation I don't even say speculation
like WV has talked about
they they're they want to do a Harry
Potter TV show but it's not clear if it
would be I think it would be set in the
future
chisel there's the rating it's T for
teen in the U.S
foreign
I agree Tom yep
watch read the books first if you can
definitely read the books first if you
can
for me I had to read the book before I
could watch the movie which honestly was
better but I wanted to watch the movie's
ASAP Gotta See Half Blood Prince of
Deathly Hallows in theaters though hey
Deathly Hallows I went to see that one
at
midnight and the theater I was watching
it at they showed part one you could you
could go early and watch part one and
then just like lead right into part two
oh it was so good
it was so good
AJ Rossi heading out
Jay Rossi thank you so much for hanging
out with us spending time here tonight
have a good one
hot take maybe but I did enjoy Goblet of
Fire movie even though I missed out on a
lot
okay
Goblet of Fire has a lot of problems as
a movie I admit I'm pretty sure I've
said this before too but
the thing that Goblet of Fire nailed was
the graveyard scene
was the graveyard scene it was so good
that was like like of all the scenes in
Goblet of Fire that you had to nail that
was the one you had to nail they nailed
it so I at least give them credit for
that I give them credit for that
because they did nail that
can we talk about Dementors and if we
will get to go to Azkaban please also
what do you think will lead us there
okay yeah so my video today
video that went up on the channel today
if you guys haven't checked it out
uh here it is this one right here the
horror of Hogwarts Legacy thought this
would be a fun one leading up to
Halloween Evil and dark magic
so I do think we will see Dementors at
some point I do
uh I mean they're they're on the cover
of the deluxe edition they were in the
first trailer and if we're going to see
the mentors
unless they're coming to Hogwarts again
which is possible
I think we have to go to Azkaban at some
point I do I think it's going to be a
potential stronghold of ancient Magic
in addition to
some of the other locations like
Gringotts which we've seen our character
going there
and Hogwarts of course
in terms of why we go there I think it's
going to be I don't know in my mind I
keep imagining these little excursions
with Professor fig being very similar to
Harry and Dumbledore in
um in Half Blood Prince
so like Harry and Dumbledore and Half
Blood Prince they're kind of like the
tag team they're going to investigate
horcruxes I feel like us our character
and fig were going to be going around to
investigate these various
strongholds of ancient magic to get it
before the goblins
and fig is the one helping us do that
and I also think those are going to be
the dungeons in the game
laughs
so I think yeah I would I think as
command is going to be a dungeon now why
we go there
yeah I think I don't think it'll be like
in prison or anything maybe there's
someone we have that is in prison that
we have to go and visit or talk to
but I think it will more be along the
lines of us going to investigate along
with fig or someone else
um going to investigate some sort of
ancient magic that could potentially be
there that's my guess
books are getting Illustrated releases
yeah they've been uh they've been
re-releasing all of them
I'm trying to remember which one just
came out a new one just came out
Dobby and Deathly Hallows right oh that
one got me Slytherin
my friends you bow to know when I cry
every time right oh it's so good
I was watch I watched that movie in
theaters with a friend from high school
and both he and I were like trying to be
all manly in front of each other you
know like
and then after the fact we were both
like we admitted to each other later
like dude I was
I was I was I was I was teary-eyed right
there and he was like me too me too
oh JP takes a lot for me to cry in real
life good books and movies oh
interesting
oh my gosh I am so far behind in chat
my apologies you guys are just I'm just
now getting into the comments of you all
when I said uh Coco
in kanto's another good one Nico yes
the Dobby scene is really well done in
movies as well you're right I've not
seen Hamilton feathers
obviously heard a lot of good things
okay Nathan was Joe I thought Nathan was
joking about the spoilers
I was hoping anyway
I don't know what we're talking about
but in Kanto yes love Encanto
oh oh my gosh guys if you're not if
you're in the Discord
you have to check out elwin's latest
tattoo
it is incredible
I'm not gonna spoil it but I'll just say
it as Harry Potter related
she commented in the chat her next
tattoo on her other arm is going to be
all Disney Disney sleeve of iconic movie
icons and images Coco is definitely the
design oh that's awesome
when Dobby died it made Ron's mom
killing Bellatrix even better right
indeed
Colin creevey in that book actually made
me tear oh right
right
Jason I can save with all you HP has
nothing to do with magic in the real
right
right exactly dude
love to see a good show I think they
could pull it off
show on the Marauders would be awesome
like they could there are so many
different paths they could take it you
know
they could go they could go pre Harry
Potter day like Hogwarts I guess he's
doing they could go
I mean I I'd love to see
something to erase cursed child
like Harry as an adult being in
a roar
an auror hold on not auror auror or it
still sounds so weird every time you
guys it sounds so weird
but a Marauder show would be cool too
um or something way into the future
like the um
the Hogwarts mystery timeline
that one would be cool too that's like
before nah that one might not be because
that one's set after Harry Potter's born
but before he gets to Hogwarts
so then you have a lot of familiar
characters there especially in terms of
the teachers
foreign
never fixed the wand right
right he never fixes the wand and like
the whole final battle
the the final battle was solid The Final
Duel with Harry and Voldemort was
and when I heard them uh I think it was
on the back to Hogwarts thing they were
talking about this
were David Yates or somebody mentioned
how
like the reason behind why they did the
whole thing with Voldemort's face
and Harry like like grabbing each other
by the head
it was basically just like yeah we just
wanted to try we thought it needed some
visual like change up or something
first of all it's supposed to be in the
Great Hall man
it's supposed to be in the Great Hall
one of the most iconic sets and places
of the whole entire series everyone's
supposed to be gathered around oh see
you got me you got me started feathers
you got me started
like how do you mess that up
how do you mess that up everything all
eight movies all seven books have been
building to this moment and you're like
nah we're gonna change it from How It
Was Written here
you know what I want to move them
outside I want to have the sequence
where they're like they're like
wrestling and they're doing all this uh
this crazy apparition
oh
but more than anything what bugs me is
that it wasn't everybody wasn't watching
everybody wasn't watching
they were all supposed to be gathered
around it was like everything else stops
and then you could just hear like the
epic music
okay not that that was not Epic
but you guys know what I mean the epic
music kicks in
and they did they just they just oh
honestly the best scene in seven was
probably part two was probably Neville's
speech like see if you're gonna change
something slightly
that's how you do it man that's how you
do it
have Neville give that that epic speech
and if you if you just read it out loud
it sounds a little cheesy yeah but when
you watch it in the books I mean in the
books when you watch it in the Heat of
the Moment in the movie it's so good I
get chills every time I watch it I do
and the music in that scene is perfect
Voldemort's return in the graveyard
scene yeah yeah they nailed that they
nailed that part I remember reading that
when I was reading that scene
dude I was legit terrified and Harry
just like the Frantic nature she did
such a good job writing that section of
like the 14 year old boy
he's just frantically thinking like
please like let him drown like maybe it
drown maybe it drowned maybe it drowned
please let it drown
[Music]
there's only one HP movie that has an
after credit scene
it's uh it's Chamber of Secrets
and it's kind of a throwaway extra
credits scene right
I know Chamber of Secrets for sure has
one Gabe
I don't know if there are any others but
it's the Chamber of Secrets it's like a
Lockhart thing just a funny little
Lockhart scene
uh right so five hey man been watching
the videos love them hey thank you so
much dude thanks for stopping by and
checking out the channel is or checking
out the live stream as well glad you
enjoy the videos
foreign
yeah you're right Ryan like we saw them
in the first trailer then the cover of
the deluxe and then nothing but yeah
they wouldn't have put them on the cover
if they weren't going to be in
like after the initial
after that first trailer I still think
they could have you know maybe they got
scrapped but then when you put them on
the cover of the deluxe
they're definitely going to be in Hey
kid want to go on a field trip to ask
right the only reason they would go
there I mean the only two possibilities
I can think of is if it's something
related to us visiting a prisoner or us
in fact
getting thrown in Azkaban which I don't
think is that I think we have to go
because we're the only one who has that
ability to detect the ancient Magic
that's what I think
definitely gonna hear the Zelda music
when you open a chest
oh my gosh I'm behind again dude you
guys are just so good about bringing up
good conversations to talk about all
right hold on I'm gonna get caught up
here
you guys are asking uh Gabe which movie
Never full on cried from a book or movie
watch black panther a couple days ago
[ __ ] a few Tuesday right that one hits
home even more or you talk about the new
one's not out yet is it you talk about
the first one
that one hits home a little bit even
harder because of uh
Chadwick
L when you have so much power now
even more power than retro
so were you not a fan of rings of power
because I've actually heard like there
was that initial
seemed like everybody hated it and then
the kind of the next wave of feedback I
heard is everybody being like no this is
actually pretty good
most people I've seen actually ended up
enjoying rings of power I've only seen
the first two episodes it's a little
slow right now but
I don't hate it
I feel like the uh The Rage of
disappointment was a little bit
overblown
but again I haven't seen it all yet so I
can't say for sure
Jim Dale says or or
well Bradley this is a little bit of an
inside joke from a uh in one of my
videos I said auror
and people just like
and all the con all the negative
comments that I've ever received on
YouTube of all the videos I've ever made
I think that one has been by far the
most
people did not
like people were
uh and and you know what a lot of
YouTube comments say don't bother me you
know it's it's YouTube people are always
gonna have there's always gonna be
negative comments people hating it
happens I let it roll off but when it's
people like names I recognize and
they're like I'm a legitimate fan of
your channel but it really bothered me
how you said that
it's like I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry
but yeah the correct pronunciation is
order but the problem is the way we
Americans say are ours like it sounds so
much better when a British person says
it
so I can like Aura aura
that's that's how it should sound but
the way we pronounce our R's it's auror
or and that just sounds so
so wrong to me so I always try every
time I see it when I'm pronouncing it
I really try and sound I'm like auror I
think auror sounds better than aura
but the way that a British person would
say it Aura Aura sounds better
so there you go
and I'm sure Jim Dale it sounds
wonderful with Jim Dale's accent
yeah I still have all my original books
except for the first my first copy of
Sorcerer's Stone was a paperback and it
just got so beat up
and so dirty I think I think we dropped
at one point outside in the rain or
something so I had to get a new one but
I still have all my other originals and
both Prisoner of Azkaban and Chamber of
Secrets are like I mean The Binding is
just totally
totally messed up it's it's like they're
if you pick up my copy of Chamber of
Secrets the book just like separates
into
Hermione what's up Hermione welcome
but I uh I have them all on Kindle now
anyway so whenever I reread I just read
my audiobook versions but I all I have
them all on my shelf I don't know maybe
someday I'll need to get a little uh
a shelf right here for them to
to exist or they could sit right there
I've got some pretty cool bookends for
them too
final fight and move in the movie was a
major disappointment
Santiago welcome
they laid out everyone in the Great Hall
it was epic
I mean the fight itself was like the
overall battle I was okay with I thought
that was good it's the hairy Voldemort
piece that
oh
um
imagine Neville gives his speech
Voldemort just uses of vodka down
and the other thing that was kind of
weird it's not how I pictured it in the
book
like Harry coming back to life or
everybody's seeing that he's actually
alive it just was not as like
I don't know I wish he had been I'm a
little hazy on I haven't read the exact
scene in the books lately so I don't
know exactly where he was positioned but
in the movies it's like he kind of just
falls out of Hagrid's arms
no he needs to be like he needs to like
throw
cloak off
and he's like standing up on a pedestal
or something and everybody
we'll see it wouldn't have uh and it
wouldn't have worked even if Voldemort
did try an akm noob
it wouldn't have worked at that point
because at that point Harry had given
actually
I don't think it would have worked on
him at that point
even if it hit I don't think it would
have killed him because
I don't know I'm a hazy on all my wand
lore right now but it's like Voldemort
had the Elder Wand
the elderon recognized Harry as the true
Master of the Elder Wand so that's why
it didn't work properly for Voldemort
that being said it will still do basic
spells I still think it would have and
then Voldemort did use it in the forest
and it was enough to kill the horcrux
that was in Harry and if Harry chose he
would have indeed died there
so I guess technically it would have
worked however after he dies for he dies
there he provides the same protection
that Lily provided to him to all the
other people at Hogwarts that's why the
curse that's why a lot of them were just
like dominating their battles they
weren't being affected
but I don't think that protection would
have passed to him
so what I'm trying to say is you might
be right it might have actually worked
on him
but I don't know he would as long as he
fired back a spell didn't matter what
spell
but as long as he fired back a spell
quick enough then he's all good
he's all good Voldemort loses
and he knew that but
Voldemort did not
see I can't even talk man and then I
lose my place okay there we go
hits them all with the I don't like long
speeches
it's the only scene that has gilderoy
Lockhart on a book with him in a
straight jacket though I don't know how
a straight jacket is in the Wizarding
World oh yeah the deleted scene or the
after credit scene
true feathers we don't know for sure but
it's I think it's almost
90 sure that that is Azkaban
but she could be right I mean it could
be someone else
uh no official confirmation on any sort
of wand customization
guys
all all they've really confirmed about
wants is that you can link your
Wizarding World account and your wand
there will carry over that's really it
Ryan likes Rings the power can't wait
for season two
uh L1 says Rings power is okay for the
big book movie nerds there's a lot that
we are like what the heck very slow
going that's that's been my biggest
critique yep
that has been my biggest critique so far
I'm only two episodes in though and I've
just been kind of like eh
or maybe I'm three episodes in
I might be three episodes in there was
one I'm like in that period where there
was one I started late at night and I
was so tired and I fell asleep toward
the end so I need to like watch the end
of that one before I go on to the new
one to the next one
dude feathers they were
they were not happy with that
pronunciation maybe I should just start
pronouncing it like the British
pronunciation aura the auras are on
their way it sounds much better doctor
thank you Dr Sherman I feel like most
people fall in that camp
but I generally do like
I mean as a Harry Potter
esque channel is a Hogwarts Legacy
Channel
I do feel like there's a certain
responsibility for me to pronounce
things correctly
so I do generally try and get it right
that's why I love the whole knuts canuts
nuts debate
I love talking about that one with
people
but but but the one the reason that aura
bothers me so much is because
it should like the way we pronounce our
R's or or like that er er or
it just sounds so weird to me
EB Games Australia keychain pre-order
announced some time ago
what is the keychain Gabe I remember
seeing this but I don't remember what
the keychain was and we still have never
gotten anything else on that Amazon
France and Germany I believe
the Hat the wizard The the
hat the wizard's hat that you get
and I've not seen any official
confirmation on that it's so strange
no your dog got a hold of the cop with a
fire hardback
yikes
shift is ending heading home for
Ravenclaw Terrell hey be safe Ravenclaw
Terrell thanks for hanging out
foreign
I mean I think any spell would have
worked I do I think any spell
although lumos is kind of a that one
doesn't like have any sort of extending
it's like a light I still think it would
have worked
or maybe it had to be some sort of spell
that sends out
to to collide with Voldemort for them to
meet
Timothy ninja bugged me but not enough
to leave a comment
please do an entire live stream in an
English accent oh man that'd be tough
people are saying it's the Canadian
pronunciation too wait do you
saying Aura like aura
the auras
like see JP Raymond fire what you just
posted there I have no idea how to
pronounce either one of them
so like the the correct like U.S
pronunciate pronunciation I've looked it
up on the Muggle net pronunciation guide
is
it's kind of like saying the word order
without the D
that's it order without the D order
now the way I pronounced it in my video
was auror
I think sounds better but hey it's not
my it's not my choice
now when British people pronounce it
though I think it sounds much better
the auras
one of my favorite lines to say with a
British accent is uh
I can't remember which movie it is I
think it might be Goblet of Fire
when Harry says to Ron you're right foul
get you know that
one of my favorite lines Dr Sherman
volunteers to train me let's go
I have not played Marvel Avengers no
oh you sent a picture of the keychain oh
good guy Nico good guy
okay let's go here
oh not a DM
but in the actual let's see Hogwarts
Legacy
wait why can I not find it
or you maybe you posted it a while back
oh wait okay you just dm'd me there we
go
noise
thank you sir thank you thank you
oh dude that is pretty cool I like that
they haven't announced anything like
that for the US
my dog's wanting to go out it's about
time to wrap it up anyway here I know
right that's pretty pretty sick
dude we in Canada follow a lot of the UK
English spelling and pronunciations how
have I never known this
Chandler said we get info on the last
tab but never did right right right
is the Scholastic pronunciation guy the
same as the British pronunciations well
it doesn't exist anymore feathers the
one that I always like to talk about
it doesn't exist anymore so I can't
remember
but I do remember
that it was pronounced knuts
no matter what anybody else says
no matter what wizardingworld.com may
tell you
it was originally pronounced knuts but
now they say the correct pronunciation
is canutz
that's right that's right every time I
say that somebody in the chat is just
like
and yes I know I know the expression I
can see through the keyboard I see
no but people always act shocked when
they're like there's always somebody
who's like wait are you serious
it's not it's not nuts like knife the K
is not silent nope
and for that one I do have the proof
I at least have the proof on on canutz
hey have a good one Logan oh okay
favorite scene favorite scene from any
Harry Potter movie
I have never thought about a specific
scene but I love that question
I just pronounce everything the way
movie flame pronounces it most of the
time movie flame gets everything correct
there was a couple there was one thing I
was watching one of his videos
I can't remember what it was recently
and I was like oh I'm pretty sure that's
wrong but I'm not gonna comment and yell
at him about it
but if he ever happened to ask I would
let him know
foreign
like we talked about the
the uh the graveyard scene I think that
was a very well done scene
oh what else I also really like the cave
scene in Half Blood Prince I think they
did a really good job with that
US Canadian spelling words with an
unnecessary U
H Color and favorite indeed
oh thank you Slytherin reviews you you
tweeted it to me as well thank you I
know right that looks so nice now
typically a lot of like Best Buy Target
Walmart GameStop for a lot of bigger
games they will usually do some sort of
like these little pre-order bonuses like
this and we still got time like they
could definitely still announce it
but I haven't seen anything at this
point
but you guys know I'll keep an eye out
for it
went to London experience and it was
Canucks yeah so that's the official
that's the official stance of like
Wizarding World and everything now is
that it's canutz
the other day I was I was making the
video about
it was the video that I made where we
were talking about Sebastian's sister
and I like I'm pretty sure I
mispronounced nagini a couple times
and I know how to pronounce nagini
but I almost I said it like nagini or
something
I said night nagini and when I was going
back when I was doing the editing
I was thinking to myself what what did I
just say
so I just edited it out and put it put
something else like in there because I
was like I I'm not going to go through
this again I'm not going to have people
yelling at me
but I think about that scene where uh
in Goblet of Fire where Voldemort says
it and it almost sounds like he says
Nike and he's like not Genie tells me
the old muggle can't take us just
outside the door
and it almost sounds like he's just
nagini there
foreign
either wait I think I thought I edited
that one out
maybe maybe I didn't get all of them
Timothy that's funny
yeah and I E nagini
yeah it's just it's just nagini
right
right
it's nagini
nagini nagini
pronounce the word Bagel as bag
oh my gosh that got me Owen
hahaha
the dark lord and his snake
this is just this has gotta become like
a regular segment
where we just uh
we just talk about like
how do you pronounce this
Harry Potter word
I'm dead
oh
any more playthroughs of the old HP
games coming okay
I want to zodiac I want to I'm torn I'm
really torn on what to do with the Let's
Plays right now I really am
um
the YouTube algorithm is a weird thing
and I there's all the stuff I'm weighing
in terms of like I want to do live
stream
I want to live streamy playing games
and I also want to do
Let's Plays but I think
I think let's plays might need their own
dedicated Channel
which I made I've made a there's a retro
record to a let's play Channel right now
it's just Elder Ring videos but
but then it's like if I ever live stream
them though I would definitely live
stream from the main channel here and
then they're already here on this
channel so it's like what will be the
point of moving them to another let's
play Channel
um but I started playing Chamber of
Secrets the PC version I want to get
through that but I'm definitely not
going to be able to do that as a live
stream because it is so complicated to
do the setup with how you have to run
that game on on PC I can't do all I need
to do in terms of the live stream side
of things on obs
so that one I might just pre-record
and then I do want to play Goblet of
Fire
as difficult as it will be to get
through it I do want to play it
about nagini the first time I saw it as
a text and I said nagini
nagini
nagini of that nagini man now see I'm
I'm from the south so we it's not quite
like a Texan accent
nagini
I know I see it like I I feel like we
need to do more gameplay live streams
for sure L1 that one in particular
though is problematic
just because of how it how it runs in
Windows
because it's a really old game
order the phoenix like that one once I
get to that one order the Phoenix and
Half Blood Prince are actually pretty
solid then you got the Deathly Hallows
games which I want to try and get
through them but I've heard they're
rough and then I may or may not do the
Lego games I love the Lego games but
they are a
bit of a nightmare for YouTube
because all the songs are copyright and
you will get claimed because it's it's
songs from the movies
now it does let you turn it off
talk about weird pronunciations I'm a
Canadian who spent most of my childhood
in the US of three summers in Texas and
Mississippi nice
all right well my dog is whining to go
out it has been almost a three hour
stream
um even with barely any news tonight
guys I've had a blast I've had I've had
a lot of fun I hope you all have enjoyed
the live stream as well hopefully we'll
get some more news later this week we
shall see but I definitely think an ASMR
is right around the corner I definitely
do hopefully by the end of October
that's I'm hoping for Halloween I think
Halloween would be a great time to do it
so
um I'm gonna wrap it up man hope you all
have a fantastic rest of your week
thank you to the mods I don't think we
had to ban anyone tonight
I don't think we had to ban anybody
but it is good to have multiple people
who can post links and post uh
oh what are those things called commands
things of that nature when we need them
so
but yeah man until next time guys
definitely check out the Discord because
we have like if you wanna right now we
only do these streams once a week I
eventually want to build up to where
we're doing more and hopefully at
different times so other people can join
but if you want to continue that
conversation a lot of people you see
here in chat tonight they're hanging out
over in the Discord so
um I just saw that Nico posted it there
in the chat so that link should be good
accurate and valid
unfortunately the keychain is only
Australia
I think it's only EB Games Australia is
what people were saying
hopefully we'll have some cool us stuff
too like dude just imagine if they threw
that in the collector's edition like
that would improve it
that would improve it a little bit
because it's not very
very
pointing
disappointing
oh goodness all right guys
have a great rest of your evening great
rest of your week and I will talk to you
again soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign